he is a physician and author of the book
and then it fell apart which launches
this Monday May 6 at the IRA thani
theater here in Los Angeles I love this
guy [ __ ] Moby's Wow how are you I am a
longtime fan a lot of Mobe in my
playlists oh I know that's a good thing
okay I can't believe it's 20 years since
play yeah as you said regarding the
Carpenters yeah oh yeah
well I you know as a musician before we
get into the heavy stuff with the book I
did want to ask you like I'm the
youngest person in my house I don't have
kids I'm the only person in my house
that's how I stay so III just you know I
I want to like the new stuff and I
always am asking my old or does it
actually suck well I got spot I think it
actually saw I got Spotify on my phone
and when I first got it I was like oh
I'm gonna hear all this new music and
immediately I use it as a nostalgia
machine and like basically Spotify is my
high school playlist like I haven't made
my musical tastes sort of end in Euro
1984 so modern music might be great but
it can't compete with the clash or
Public Enemy or John Lennon or Neil
Young on and on and on
you were very much on the cusp of
something that everybody doesn't know
that you were many things at once I may
be wrong about this but you weren't just
the musician and you sometimes sang you
say but you were like a curator and a DJ
and a producer it was like I make this
record I'm on it but then if I want to
put something else into what I do that
too because originally originally I
wanted to be a singer but I'm not a
great singer so I had to learn how to do
everything else and I so it wasn't like
like that old adage necessities a motor
mother of invention I wanted to be Bono
or David Bowie but my singing voice is
really mediocre so I had to learn
instruments in production and DJing to
sort of like overcompensate for the fact
that I'm a shitty singer but with
auto-tune no one is a shitty song
nowadays that is true yeah and that's
one thing I don't like about the modern
shot okay but what I love about like but
I do like complaining about young people
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but what I really loved about your book
and the first 1/2 hour but this is your
second memoir okay and you're very
honest you know when even in memoirs
people are not I mean you say you'd love
the adulation you've drank it up like a
thirsty sponge
most people are don't admit that you say
you know you look at Trent Reznor
mmm-hmm you had all the women you wanted
women to adore you like that look it's
very honest cuz I grew up very poor
right and in a very dysfunctional home
with like sexual abuse and violence and
mental illness and I thought that Fame
was going to fix everything and so I
pursued it desperately and for a while
it worked I mean there were those
moments where I was like out of my mind
on like liquor and drugs and having sex
with strangers in the bathroom and like
that was great
but not sustainable and then I found
myself chasing the dragon as a lot of
aging celebrities do right like so
suddenly like you're in the basement of
a strip club saying to like the bouncer
it's 3:00 in the morning don't you know
who I am and you're like
well yes there's that part of it but I
certainly wouldn't want to turn the kids
off to random sexy drugs no it's it's a
rite of passage everyone should go
through well yeah I mean you know you
don't have to be I mean in your book
it's basically you know you had a hole
in your soul and sex and drugs did not
fill it no and I tried and tried and
tried and tried and dry I mean late it's
not the worst journey to beyond no come
up to empty at the edge that's all I'm
saying okay so I've asked this of all
the guests we've had on the show
have you ever rubbed your penis against
Donald Trump as a matter of fact as most
of the guests would say yes I have tell
me about it
so no I read it in your book there was
one night was been out 2001 I was out at
a party and I was very drunk I'm sober
now yeah and and I was with some friends
and they were telling me about this game
that they used to play in college called
nob touch and I really shouldn't be
divulging this in public but it is in
the book so nob touch is when you take
your flaccid penis out of your pants
lasted and these days my penis is all
this less cos natural and you you walk
around a room and you brush your flaccid
penis up against people indiscriminate
snot sexual there's no gender involved
and the goal is see like Biden yeah
it's just inappropriate and and I'm not
saying he does that I'm just saying it's
not so I was very drunk and my friends
told me about Knob touch and my
girlfriend the time dared me to Knob
touch Donald Trump right so I've only
rubbed my flaccid penis against one
person in the entire world and that man
is currently on a golden toilet in the
White House
tweeting about
[Applause]
girls like I wish I could do the same
I'm gonna do knob touch with them as
soon as I can okay I mean yeah it's um
it's it's I probably wouldn't do that
now that I'm like old and sober right
but at the time I was blackout drunk
absolutely the Beatles got high when
they got their MBEs from the you know
the metals from the British Empire you
gotta do it Willie Nelson get stoned in
the way Keith Richards yeah Keith
Richards shot up in Rocco's you're a
rock star you deserve some rock star
[ __ ] and one of my heroes cause like me
you're an animal lover and you're a real
activist you have a vegan restaurant
did you see beyond meets and beyond
Berger these companies now I've noticed
myself out at restaurant the veggie
burger is not what it was two years ago
they finally got it with the veggie
burger they acted this is gonna be a big
thing right I hope I'm not gonna vegan
for 31 years Wow and honestly animal
rights is my life's work like my
restaurant little pine 100% of the
profits goes to animal rights
organizations same thing with this book
general fell apart 100% of the profits
goes to rights organizations so
entrepreneurially I'm an idiot like 100
percent of my profits go to Elmo rights
organizations because I wanted to talk
to jay Inslee if he's still here so
he'll be here later
about climate change he lives here now
oh okay because whenever people talk
about climate change they ignore animal
agriculture you agree and animal
agriculture is the third leading cause
of climate change like talking about
climate change and not addressing animal
agriculture is like talking about lung
cancer and not talking about smoking so
America and everyone if in any way
but then again I would also say I don't
like humans very much so like maybe you
should keep eating bacon and burgers and
destroy yourselves like yet get obese I
think took that one subway
you